[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ce dossier sensible je vais partager
avec vous une interprétation
depuis plus d'un an le président roh
macron à préparer ses premiers mois de
présidence européenne
en comptant l'utiliser sur tous les
plans pour contribuer à sa réélection il
était convaincu que le retrait annonce
la chancelière allemande le
positionnerait comme le chef naturel
d'une europe à laquelle il imposerait
ses vues et je suis lui permettre et et
montre aux français que grâce à lui
l'avenir de leur pays pas c'est
dorénavant par l'union européenne ce qui
correspondait à la fois à ses
convictions oren nostalgiques de
grandeur qui caractérise nombre de nos
concitoyens
la réalité allemande est venue frapper
ce plan de plein fouet en faisant
apparaître de nombreuses divergences qui
vont tout compliquer à la surprise
générale c'est olaf scholz ministre des
finances et chef du parti
social-démocrate située à gauche qui a
gagné les élections contre les verts et
la cdu donné favori en moins de deux
mois soit moitié moins que celui dont
avait eu besoin la chancelière en 2017
il a ensuite construit un accord du
gouvernement tricolore avec les verts et
les libéraux et en définitive on voit
que cette coalition progressiste veut
changer l'allemagne en profondeur en
quatre ans le programme commun qu'il
s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre vise à
conforter clairement le leadership
européen de l'allemagne grandes
puissances économiques qui selon edouard
husson dans atlantico se refusent
d'exercer un leadership diplomatique en
europe ou dans le monde comme
l'expliquent hans stark spécialiste de
l'allemagne à l'ifri il s'agit d'assumer
un leadership depuis le centre est de
placer berlin en position donne est
courtier y compris avec les etats unis
et pour ça berlin s'appuiera sur trois
axes principaux
la défense
avec le temps et les états unis
l'économique avec la chine et l'europe
et l'énergie avec la russie notons que
le couple franco allemand n'est cité
qu'une fois dans un texte de 177 pages
par le souhait de liens privilégiés puis
à le traiter d'aix la chapelle et
l'assemblée parlementaire franco
allemande qui en est issu il est vrai
que l'allemagne est notre premier
partenaire économique
depuis le début la vème république
alors que nous ne le sommes plus depuis
2015 ou la chine nous a remplacé pour
comprendre ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains mois il est intéressant
d'identifier les principaux objectifs de
nouveau chancelier et de les comparer à
la position française le président du
parti libéral et nouveau ministre des
finances un premier au nom de la
coalition de ne pas introduire de
nouveaux impôts sur les actifs et les
plus aisés de ne pas augmenter les
prélèvements tels que l'impôt sur le
revenu l'impôt sur la société ou la taxe
sur la valeur ajoutée et de revenir à
l'équilibré des comptes publics tout en
lançant un plan d'investissement massif
et ceci sera réalisée en même temps
qu'une réduction de la dette dès 2023
l'objectif étant de rembourser 60
milliards ce n'est pas rien 60 milliards
par an dès 2026 pour retrouver
l'équilibré des finances allemandes en
disant alors au niveau économique
européen pour éviter de nouveaux
dérapages de la dette dans les pays du
sud dont nous faisons partie
la coalition veut lier la révision du
pacte de stabilité et croissance à une
transformation des économies européennes
en associant ses dépenses un programme
de réformes favorables au renforcement
de la compétitivité des économies
nationales nous sommes donc loin de la
position française du quoi qu'il en
coûte il est vrai qu'au delà de la
renégociation des critères de maastricht
qui ont contribué un excédent commercial
allemand impressionnant et un déficit
commercial français
désastreux la trajectoire opposée des
dettes publiques et privées 116% et 156
% pour la france contre 70 et 100 8%
pour l'allemagne constitue comme le
rappelle nicolas baverez dans le point
un risque majeur pour la pérennité de
l'euro
dans le domaine de la défense la
coalition est clairement en retrait par
rapport aux positions dans ghana merkel
sur la construction d'une europe plus
souveraine rien n'est dit sur la défense
européenne où l'europe de la défense le
cap est temps visiblement de s'appuyer
sur les états unis dans le cadre de
l'alliance atlantique elle réaffirme
donc la primauté de l'otan pilier
central
indispensable à la sécurité de
l'allemagne qui doit faire l'objet d'une
coopération plus intense avec l'union
européenne
dans ce cadre les forces allemandes vous
renforcer le pilier européen de l'otan
comme cela avait déjà été mentionné dans
une émission précédente de la source et
la coalition pro met en cause les
interventions extérieures de la
bundeswehr et pour réduire les coûts va
privilégier le matériel acheté sur
étagère au détriment des grands
programmes dont nombre et en partenariat
avec des entreprises françaises après
d'autres le programme d'hélicoptères
tigre risque d'en être la prochaine
victime au profit du âge 64 apache de
boeing de plus et c'est pas le moindre à
20 sous la pression des verts il semble
privilégier une politique de désarmement
qui passe par un projet de limitation
des exportations d'armes à l'échelle
européenne qui nous concerne évidemment
directement et peut être catastrophique
pour l'industrie de défense française et
ce recentrage sur le temps au détriment
d'une armée européenne
sa compagne au niveau militaire d'un
accompagnement allemand de la stratégie
de basculement américaine vers l'ennemi
chinois alors que c'est son premier
partenaire économique
la partie de l'inconscient dans les
lignes directrices pour la région indo
pacifique précise
qu'elles représentent 20% de son
commerce extérieur
tandis que la frégate allemande bayern
faisait tuer escale au japon dans le cas
d'une mission de six mois dans la région
blanc les nude en défense info du mi
novembre nous signale que le chef
d'état-major de la luftwaffe le général
in guk ehrhart annoncé que six avions de
combat eurofighter typhoon accompagnés
par trois a400m et 3 avions
ravitailleurs serait envoyé en australie
en septembre 2022 afin de prendre part à
l'exercice biennal pitch black
selon marie un sma lucci d'associations
de presse le chef de la marine allemande
le vice amiral qui est acquis marche
hambach a déclaré à tokyo que ses
missions phys à nouer de nouvelles
relations plus étroites avec les pays
démocratiques de la région comme le
japon l'australie ou encore l'inde pour
limiter sa dépendance au marché chinois
défendre le droit international et la
liberté de navigation en particulier en
mer de chine et promouvoir le dialogue
pour résoudre les différends
territoriaux et éviter les conflits
potentiels
après la décision brutale et mal étudiés
dollars et dû nucléaire pas la
chancelière allemande pour des raisons
purement électoralistes il a fallu
rouvrir les centrales électriques au
charbon avec pour conséquence la montée
du taux de pollution en allemagne et
dans les pays limitrophes
la coalition a donc décidé d'arrêter
définitivement charbon en 2030 au lieu
de 2038 initialement fixé elle s'est
aussi fixé comme objectif à cette même
date de couvrir 80% de la consommation
d'électricité par des énergies
renouvelables contre 40% aujourd'hui
grâce à un soutien massif dont l'éolien
et de l'énergie solaire quand on regarde
de cela on voit que le premier
engagement est rendue possible par
l'arrivée du gaz russe venu parler d'eux
nord stream le second par son
utilisation en remplacement si le plan
avait du retard
compte tenu cette dépendance au gaz
russe
indispensable à la transition
énergétique allemande on comprend
pourquoi la coalition prônant un
dialogue constructif avec moscou qui
nous éloigne des tensions actuelles
comme ceci est dans la lignée également
choisi par le président biden qui ne
peut se battre à la fois contre la chine
et la russie ceci devrait provoque une
accalmie progressive entre la russie et
l'europe en dépit de l'opposition
politique de quelques pays du nord et de
l'est et sachant que l'inde du gaz gaz
russe est en allemagne ce pays va tout
faire pour en vendre en europe au nom de
la diversification de
l'approvisionnement énergétique et les
partisans du nucléaire vont devoir se
battre lors fermement pour faire
accepter leurs solutions alternatives
l'allemagne est confrontée à un déclin
démographique rapide et a aussi un
vieillissement de la population qui
avait amené la chancelière à ouvrir ses
frontières
ceci explique les relations privilégiées
avec la turquie
d'eau sont issus la plus grande partie
des travailleurs immigrés dans une
analyse récente alexandre robin et
borgomano d'atlantico rappelle que pro
la coalition l'allemagne est un pays
d'immigration moderne où des hommes et
des femmes de nombreux pays on trouve
leurs foyers fondé des familles et
gagner leur vie
pourquoi la lutte contre l'immigration
elle privilégie
l'intégration des immigrés sur le marché
du travail c'est pourquoi elle veut
rendre la loi sur l'immigration des
travailleurs qualifiés plus pratique et
introduire un système de points comme
deuxième pilier pour attirer les
travailleurs qualifiés berlin considère
l'immigration choisie s'accompagnant du
roman familial comme un apport
indispensable pour augmenter la
population active ce qui se traduit par
l'ouverture de la naturalisation après
cinq années de séjour je rappelle qu'en
france et dix ans et c'est donc une
position presque opposée à celle qui est
majoritaire en france dans le pré accord
de coalition publié le 15 octobre les
trois parties écrivent nous voulons
renforcer l'union européenne afin de
renforcer l'allemagne nous allons donc
définir les intérêts allemands à la
lumière des intérêts européens
alors sachant que l'allemagne se
considère comme centrale en europe tant
comme première puissance économique
qu'en termes de positionnement
géographique
le nouveau chancelier 10,2 froid dans
son programme qu'il veut accroître la
souveraineté stratégique de l'europe
dans les domaines de l'approvisionnement
énergétique des matières premières de la
santé et du numérique et il ajoute que
voulant mener à bien sa refondation
allemande au milieu d'un marché européen
structuré il est partisan de développer
l'option du fédéralisme alors pour mener
à bien cette politique européenne active
la coalition a la volonté de travailler
dans le cadre d'un partenariat
franco-allemand solide et d'une
coopération permanente dans le cadre il
faut le préciser du triangle de weimar
qui associe la france à la
réconciliation germano polonaise
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
caroline galatée rose qui est la
fondatrice du pôle de géostratégie
réaliste géo pragma à qui j'ai demandé
de bien vous à réagir et compléter mon
interprétation
caroline bonjour bonjour alain bienvenu
dans la source
pour nous donner votre éclairage
parfaitement une première question
on la coalition tricolore parle de
souveraineté stratégiques européennes
ne pensez vous pas qu elle la conçoit en
étant en réalité la puissance centrale
de l'europe
vous commencez par une question de fond
je pense que l'allemagne a pris
conscience et assument de plus en plus
ouvertement quelle est la puissance
centrale en europe la nouvelle coalition
donc est une coalition
spd libéraux et grünen sachant que les
verts allemands n'ont pas grand chose à
voir avec les verts français mais on y
reviendra peut-être a décidé d'exprimer
je pense beaucoup plus encore que durant
l'ère merkel cette puissance mais de
manière intelligente est habile c'est à
dire autour d'eux
2 2
prétexte mofaz qui ne sont pas seulement
des prétextes sont des moteurs et qui à
mon avis ils vont être effectivement
l'europe comme alpha et oméga et et
enveloppes commode de politique de
puissance et l'écologie d'ailleurs la
ministre
des affaires étrangères enfin on la
ministre de l'économie est aussi celle
de l'écologie et la ministre des
affaires étrangères et une verte ce qui
est quand même très très intéressant au
delà des alliances de circonstance du
aux équilibres politiques internes c'est
aussi un message non justement celle
influence écologique en particulier on
l'a connu en allemagne même si les verts
n'ont rien à voir avec nos verres à nous
ce que c'est le cas de le dire mais tu
as quand même un phénomène qui meurt
dans laquelle qui m'interpelle et sur le
q j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
on assiste depuis quelques mois à des
ruptures unilatérale par les allemands
d'un certain nombre de grands contrats
d'armement et hills en annonce d'autres
clairement bon dans le même temps on lit
dans le protocole de la collision qu' il
soit ils vont pousser au niveau européen
le désarmement hors europe pour les
toutes les ventes d'armements europe
alors la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est dans le fond tout cela n'est-il
pas les deux faces d'une stratégie qui
vise à casser l'industrie de défense
française alors profite évidemment
je ne suis pas loin de le croire je
pense que tout ce discours tous et
habillage et aussi tout ce que ça va
donner concrètement dans des décisions
ou des déclarations en matière
diplomatique autour finalement d'une
vision de nouveau
très idéaliste et très moraliste aussi
de la diplomatie va permettre
effectivement de pouvoir justifier
des encouragements au démantèlement de
l'industrie européenne de la défense
dans la mesure où celles-ci existent
sachant qu évidemment la france est un
acteur majeur et en plus des positions
et des intérêts différents ça s'était
déjà vu il ya d'ailleurs avant cette
nouvelle coalition ça s'est vu à propos
des livraisons d'armes d'ailleurs à
l'arabie saoudite ça s'est vu à
plusieurs reprises on sent que c'est une
tendance de fond et je pense que
l'allemagne va se servir d'un en fait à
une diplomatie vraiment écologique très
écologique oui parce que justement on
vous en parlement européen il ya
quelques mois déjà il ya une
représentante des verts allemands qui a
proposé que toutes les exportations
d'armes en dehors de l'europe soit
d'abord préalablement agréées par le
parlement européen et nous savons qu'à
ce moment là effectivement rien ne
sortira mais c'est une manière de
replacer gentiment
l'europe et d'ailleurs c'est clairement
dit dans le contrat de coalition
la sécurité européenne est envisagée que
dans le cadre de l'otan et donc cette
tout tout s'est tu
advocacy pole ici si vous voulez autour
des thèmes de l'idéalisme de lalala de
la moralité du moralisme en politique
internationale de l'écologie et de tout
un tas de choses tout ça va servir en
fait à remettre l'europe au pas et bien
sûr à la remettre entre les mains
plus que jamais de l'otan et des états
unis et c'est là qu'on peut c'est là
qu'on peut comprendre que bien sûr il ya
ce deal
ce deal implicite ou peut-être
d'ailleurs très explicite entre eux je
n'en sais rien entre entre américains et
allemands c'est à dire et nous en sommes
bien sûr les victimes
les victimes potentielles et des
victimes déjà assez clairement désigné
il s'agit de faire en sorte que l'europe
bien sûr ne soit de soi puissante à
aucun prix tout à fait alors justement
il il faut quand même que les français
réagissent une salle d'une manière ou
d'une autre et on peut se poser une
question bug made puisque maintenant on
va voir la présidence européenne
française quand même c'est le nucléaire
parce que ils ont décidé d'abandonner et
il le confirme ils ont abandonné le
nucléaire et l'hiver sont clairement
contre le nucléaire alors est ce que
dans le fond le fait est ce que la
france en dix ans nous nous
n'abandonnons pas le nucléaire est suivi
par un certain nombre de pays est-ce que
c'est pas le moment justement pour la
france de fédérer tous ces pays qui
veulent continuer sur le nucléaire parce
que c'est un moyen efficace de réduire
le jir et le niveau de carbone sans pour
autant poser trop de problèmes
économiques est-ce que c'est pas
justement un moyen pour les français de
reprendre un petit peu d'initiatives
dans un environnement qui s'annonce
plutôt noir
oui je pense que c'est le cas de le dire
l'environnement c'est l'environnement
s'annonce noire au propre et au figuré
pour nous je pense évidemment que
tout ce qui encourage
la pérennisation et le développement de
nos capacités et de notre savoir faire
et de notre supériorité en matière de
technologie nucléaire est très important
et doit être doit être maintenu et
encourager de toutes les façons je ne
sais pas si les dernières déclarations
présidentielles à ce sujet qui sont
quand même le reflet d'une volte face
intéressante après quatre années au
contraire de déconstruction et de
discours négatifs sur le nucléaire et de
projet d'abandon d'une partie de nos
capacités nucléaires je ne sais pas si
ce revirement cette volte face sera
durable
sera sera reprise et est mise en oeuvre
véritablement mais c'est évident que
c'est un c'est pour nous un pilier d'un
fluence très importants auxquels nous
devons renoncer à aucun prix n'est
certainement pas sous des prétextes
idéologiques
message contient sur les tous d'accord
nous on n'a pas de solution nous on a
pas du gaz qui arrivent par nos longs
stream-2 nous il faut qu'on utilise le
nucléaire c'est clair exactement 1 oui
une autre question c'est ce concernant
ce nouveau chancelier alors on dit qu'on
le connaît bien il aura connu
communistes des finances on l'a connu
comme vice chancelier avec angela merkel
mais en définitive entre comme nouveau
chancelier venant du spd ayant fait
cette coalition cette coalition
tricolore comme on l'appelle
est ce qu'à votre avis ça va changer
vraiment les relations franco allemandes
est ce que ça valait amplifier une
tendance par rapport à précédemment est
ce que ça va changer
qu'est-ce qui veut qu est ce qui
pourrait se passer essayons de passe de
penser au futur qu'est ce qui pourrait
se passer avec ce nouveau chancelier
qu'on connaît et qu'on ne connaît pas un
quand même parce que
d'abord ne l'a pas vu à l'oeuvre comme
chancellier exactement 2 et deuxièmement
nous mêmes nous sommes à l'orée
peut-être d'un changement
de pouvoir et donc d'orientation
politique et pourquoi pas géopolitique
et une autre peut-être d'une autre
conception de l'europe plus
plus plus fondées éventuellement sur le
poids des nations et des états et donc
en fait l'enjeu c'est comment va évoluer
l'europe si on se retrouve avec deux
européiste qui pour des raisons
différentes et des intérêts différents
convergent vers
la mise en valeur d'un projet qui est à
mon avis extrêmement abstrait parce que
les rapports de puissance de toute façon
demeure et le rapport de force de toute
façon existe pour les bleus même si on
pas même si on est dans leur pays ce
noël plus béat il est clair quand on lit
ce contrat de coalition que c'est un
contrat de puissance et d'influencé tout
à fait assumée allemand c'est à dire ça
n'est pas parce que ce n'est plus un
gala mercal que ça va être une coalition
molle je ne pense pas du tout je pense
que c'est c'est très bien comment
dirais-je marquer tu essaies tu sais tu
sais c'est d'ailleurs l'idée c'est oser
plus de progrès ils ont repris la finale
ment aux et plus de démocratie de
l'époque de willy brandt donc ça se veut
moderniser sa se veut progressiste ça se
veut inclusif ça se veut d'ailleurs il
ya des aspects
culturelles et
notamment une politique immigrationniste
là aussi extrêmement ouverte
donc il ya toute une idée de ce que doit
devenir l'europe
de ce qu'elle doit
promouvoir comme comme de nouveau une
idéologie en fait c'est à dire je trouve
que c'est assez inquiétant si vous
voulez donc et je ne pense pas que dans
un rapport de forces
franco allemand avec quelqu'un qui a
aussi pour d'autres raisons
besoin de l'européisme comme comme
flambeau eh bien nous nous tirerons
notre épingle du jeu dans ce couple
franco allemand qui reste très
hasardeuse merci caroline merci beaucoup
pour tout ces analyses et
interprétations
c'est qu'ils nous permettent aux plus
permettront aux auditeurs de mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe et cette
évolution en cours et puis surtout
l'impact sur les relations
franco-allemandes merci encore
s'il est vrai que la vision européenne
de la présidence française
repose sur une robe supérieur aux états
on est loin de l'autonomie stratégique
européenne défendue par notre président
pour une europe qui protège au delà des
éléments de langage cher aux diplomates
il faut reconnaître que la finalité du
document allemand ne va pas dans le sens
des intérêts français comme le constate
et je citais tout à l'heure nicolas
baverez ce temps le point dès lors que
l'on quitte les grands principes pour en
venir à leur déclinaison concrète et à
la réponse aux défis qui se présentent
les divergences et les motifs de
discorde se multiplient la réussite de
la coalition tricolore autour du
chancelier choses pourraient bien nous
faire regretter angela merkel qui a dit
lui selon challenges entre sa conception
de l'avenir de l'allemagne est la mienne
il y a une différence
gigantesque à bientôt
[Musique]